what happened phone call important stuff
yeah Derek yes sir
okay where are you about to walk out
clear I just heard nothing Donna you're
outside Dunkin Donuts Travis we need you
sitting down so I get I'm at the
register now okay you're at the register
I want you to tell tell the lady riddle
me this
hold on one second
okay when she gets back say riddle me
this what would a bottom like what would
a boy like me have to do for a dozen
doughnuts
what would uh Oh big guy like a little
boy like me has to do for say I need
something special it's the trap door
Travis definitely some strawberry
frosted like maybe three of those yeah
so let me get say uh riddle me this did
you chocolate frosted riddle means it
you have chocolate okay three chocolate
frosted ask for green strawberry three
chocolate ask for a salmon right
doughnut salmon ride doughnut you have
that they don't have that yeah and also
say you're gonna get six more said you
got a gallon of birch beer you don't
have you never know you say ignoring me
can I get a gallon of beer you don't
have one question
oh you want me to pay now okay I'm not
moving fast enough
okay ask her if she could not she giving
you the Dozen yeah but she's a receipt
she's moving me along too bad you're
ordering your customers say this say uh
hey miss can you give me a sack of
boysenberries
what kind of berry a sack of
boysenberries say miss I need a sack of
boysenberries
you have boysenberry now no you're not
as
team right that just becomes some kind
of berry have any berries no no wrong
miss I'm gonna sack of poison berries
you don't have Voisin berry right now
they don't have it she's getting upset
too many games to China we're done cream
no no no say I say say miss I need a
Boston creamer okay wait how many Boston
cream one I want I want one Boston
creamer and then uh and Britain say this
and say and what are those pecker shape
doughnuts you have oh that's a whole
dozen are you know no say what are those
what are those pecker shape doughnuts
yeah say what are those pecker shape
doughnuts I just pushed along here okay
okay I don't think he's not you're
panicking Dunkin Donuts you're not in
[ __ ] Manhattan Supreme Court yeah we
need to find out what the pecker shaped
doughnuts are you have like those long
like bag oh wait a sec you know the
pecker bagel shape one the one that
tastes like a pecker no they don't have
it they don't have it trans needs a
coffee yeah give me a nice time I was
well you get back in
Travis dog Derek you get the Munchkins
oh good five down there go to a
different register dead online there's
only two who then get a get back online
and tell the lady
I forgot my munch keys yeah I'm sorry
for the confusion I forgot to order my
munch keys yeah how many come in a thing
I don't know let's see I don't see the
menu to ask how many how many monkeys
you get how many monkeys is one order
there's a 10 pound or 25 pounds now I
know that we don't know we don't need
you to say we need you to ask her that
ask ask you how many munch keys will
fill your tummy I just forgot I need to
get a box of monkeys two monkeys how
many comes in two monkeys how many
monkeys will fill my tummy just enough
to fill would ya know ask gross she
could take a crawler and put too much
skis around it community over there did
you where's the ice coffee yeah you're
gonna have to get back to get that - yes
you got the munchies though oh it's over
here wait what kind of iced coffee just
the large iced coffee black large iced
coffee black like my men like my men no
I'm like a joke for the movie airplane
just say it no eating it the iced coffee
for Travis dog egg please yeah Travis
dog wants an iced coffee
Oh wolf wolf that's how you order it is
that it yes that's the last thing we'll
wait yeah we'll make your decision yes
yeah like its men just and when you get
up there say I need an iced coffee for
the Travis dog move over okay okay
one right downstairs but it's it's nine
o'clock is it really still busy oh it's
rush hour for coffee for sure oh is it
yeah cool how many more people had yeah
everyone's running
late trying to get their coffee how many
people how do you disappear
just one okay ask if you can go ahead oh
she's in the middle 400 that'll be great
next two line can I cut you the Travis
dog is hungry it's his birthday
Bufo Bufo oh I just looked at a mirror I
forgot I was a stupid haircut - oh now
you say miss can you hurry up the Travis
targets thirsty I just need one more
thing for the Travis so I need a large
black thank you all right I think I
think I think we're good say I would
give you a tip but I'm running low on
cash I'm Marty yeah there's someone's
already at the register they cut in
front of them just to say sorry miss no
tip come on there's all the Travis wants
you to for his birthday
I don't even know what number I am there
zero you're not even giving me receipts
anymore at this point they're just fed
up oh you didn't get a receipt just go
get one and say sorry and when you get
the ring get a receipt say I'm sorry I
didn't cut it cut the line say I'm sorry
I didn't get a receipt yeah and then say
sorry miss no tip will you say miss can
I get a receipt for [ __ ] tax
purposes you got to get a receipt dude
yeah
that's where we can reimburse you yeah
otherwise this is on you okay get that
receipt for the iced coffee actually max
pertussis I just get there a thief or
you know for tax purposes
I'd say thanks no tip
[Music]
give her a tiptoe you got a tip the lady
thank you so much say no tip you won't
say no it's safe just kidding there you
go have a good day
I gave her two dollars you did yeah
so you got the Munchkins in the donuts
though yep okay I'm out of there all
right that was that was not fun we got
uncomfortable for you oh hey hey Josh
the first cast the first cast me off and
then gave me the other the other one
because you just didn't want to deal
with me anymore then the manager was the
one handling me good good well where'd
they travel all right dudes I'll come
back thanks Derek you go you haven't
gonna stop yeah I'll get your egg I love
you thank you bye pumpkin there we go
all right
I'm gonna sit down on the couch yeah
that's hot hot stuff
hot stuff Derek is not nice I don't know
why you shake your body you don't have
to wear the lipstick but you have to
dance like you have to do like a
striptease and you have to use the
doughnuts as like breasts
okay fair did we compromise buddy all
right all right there we go we're all
about compromise here we want to make
sure everybody leaves happy that's right
just get a couple of those doughnuts
maybe some of the Boston creamers uh
which number is that choice
uh-huh uh six okay six on hold on okay
yeah yeah yeah okay do we got time what
kind of time are we like we got okay by
the way if Travis leaves here if Travis
leaves here with coming his balls you're
fired the end of strip
you don't need the music got 30 take
that [ __ ] hoodie off that's it and get
those under get get get that shoes off
stop wasting time with the [ __ ]
hoodie let's step on my feet yeah awful
come on get your [ __ ] pants off yeah
that belt comes off now whip Travis's
eyes oh he's shaking his bare bottom in
transit but he's sure day this has been
Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
[Music]